hello and welcome to this video playing
room rollin or nine and never played him
so what do we get this opening yeah i'm
just playing the symmetrical here
ninety-five never saw that one
interesting probably just going back 95
interesting move
yes what so so I'm checking this and if
I go see six now I cannot even calculate
this stuff it's really kind of
irritating let's go see six pack I mean
everything is hanging this is really
working for white I have a hard time to
believe it Knight f6 Queen f6 this is
definitely losing a piece so that's not
working I don't believe this year am I
not just winning a pc md5 yes this is
this is something maybe 95 95 85 and cb5
and I'm a piece up right
now that's a piece okay the only thing
is if he gets gets d6 or something
that's a little bit tricky Queens you
for also go and you fall hmm coogi for
castles bishop age six is not so clear
yeah this immediately of course also in
there also possible Green h4 I was
thinking then he has to cancel hmm yeah
that's not the greatest bishop ever I
probably have to do something with f six
trying to get rid of that porn and later
develop the bishop I think something
like that ok he will Castle I guess and
now I'm doing the same
maybe I can do maybe before as an idea
before then be six and then we should be
seven yeah Queen eh FOIA is not a app
didn't play that in order to checkmate
him also but to prevent Quincy for that
or smaller defensive move then then an
actual attacking move so like b6 rupee
84 should be several this kind of thing
will be a diff if he attacks it with
Queen f3r 25 yes they'll have to still
have to be precise ok so here Queen age
3 I guess that makes a bishop coming to
the long diagonal really interesting
prospect ok now i have to move the
bishop i cannot play b 6i guess
unfortunately so back here but i have
queen e6 coming and maybe then f6
breaking up at a 56 construction
yeah tries to get to get g7
yeah let's castle Sookie paint it's not
easy at all really isn't maybe you
should be eight yeah Bishop to eat that
is probably making some sense got
everything on the back rank
even though f4 becomes a real option now
now still it's a piece it is abby's so 3
into 6 I think come on let's get rid of
this Queens somewhat dominating position
B 6 h-4 and just g6 song okay again the
moment this Bishop is coming into the
game or h6 maybe h6 not allowing book FY
have six stuff like that
yeah poor got that Bishop into the game
really good news so Queen d5 is trading
Queens it's got two points he's got two
pawns we are check the gladly take you
five check
no okay it's the kind of tricky even
though it was a look like a full piece
getting the clock wonder okay white
resins Jim that opening didn't work at
all never saw 95 in this position I mean
it's probably not terrible or so but we
did move a kid computer once do this
which makes some sense but it's very
that's very very boring just kind of
thing ok so I went here and now he took
that and it just just doesn't work
really yeah okay okay I should have
played 25 here huh check that was that
was much simpler to not I get into this
weird structure with the pawn on d6
Quincy for was moved that also was
considering how the computers reply is
actually good bashai it yeah that makes
lots of sense actually put it back and
make sure that I get some how
coordinated later it's difficult to
otherwise keep the Jeep on I'm a king of
a door so this doesn't look good and as
well here and it's it probably wins for
black but it's it's a matter of some
some some some some precision so stop
with this Bishop on back on c 8 mmhmm
yeah better be careful okay well thanks
for watching